hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math a
lot less stressful and more enjoyable so
let's get right into this video we're
going to talk about some probability
examples with cards like you know a
standard deck of 52 playing cards so a
lot of students I work with they're not
card players so when they get to these
problems they freak out a little bit
because they they're just not familiar
they didn't grow up playing cards it's a
complete foreign concept so let me see
if I can just break this down hopefully
this will help some of you in the
watching this video there's 52 cards in
your basic card deck 26 of them are red
and 26 are black so it's split in half
right 13 our hearts and 13 our diamonds
okay because the red ones are split in
half 13 our hearts 13 your diamonds the
black ones are split in half 13 our
spades like a shovel right and 13 our
clubs okay looks like a three leaf
clover there okay but then you can
further divide those 13 hearts into
three face cards so they have a face on
them they're kings queens and Jack's
okay and then you've got the numbered
cards which are two through ten okay and
then there's one ace so each suit they
call these four suits okay of 13 cards
are made up of a three face cards the
numbered cards 2 through 10 and then the
ace okay so let's get into some examples
and I'll show you how to work with them
some probability examples here are using
playing cards my first one says what is
the probability of being dealt four face
cards and one ace okay so that's an
interesting question so first we have to
analyze how many face cards there are
and you can see there's three six nine
twelve so out of 12 face cards
okay we're choosing four now these are
reading i'm using combinations is
because when you're dealt these cars
when you hold them in your hand it
doesn't matter you know what order
they're they're dealt to you so we don't
want to use permutations we want to use
combinations because the order is not
important but then we're going to
multiply this by all different ways to
get one ace now there's an ace of hearts
diamonds spades and clubs so out of the
four aces we just want to find out how
many ways there are to choose
one well of course there's four ways
right but we can use it as a combination
for choose one and then we're going to
divide that by the total possible
five-card hands so out of 52 cards total
how many ways are there to choose five
where the order doesn't matter so
probability is the number of successful
outcomes the number of things that you
want to occur right divided by the total
possible things that could occur so if
you simplify this you know out you're
going to be able to calculate what the
probability is and just a quick note
here I'll just show you with the 12
choose 4 this is 12 factorial over 12
minus 4 8 factorial 4 factorial 4 choose
1 is 4 factorial over 4 minus 1 3
factorial 1 factorial all divided by 52
factorial 52 minus 5 which is 47
factorial 5 factorial so if you simplify
that you're going to get the probability
okay let's look at another example it
says what is the probability of being
Delta King followed by an ace so you're
basically being dealt one card and then
another card it's like reaching into a
hat what's the probability I picked this
out set it aside pick another card now
well the thing to notice here is that
it's not like you're shuffling that card
back into the deck so there's this
concept of with replacement or without
replacement so this is without
replacement ok which means that these
events are dependent on one another as
opposed to when you shuffle it back in
they would be independent that
probabilities would be restored to the
original probabilities so what we're
going to do here is we're going to look
at hmm probably being Delta King well
there's four kings okay and there's 52
cards total so the probability is four
chances out of 52 right but once you're
dealt that King now what happens there's
only 51 cards left right and we say
what's the probability being dealt an
ace we can see there's four aces out of
the 51 remaining cards so if we multiply
these together we're going to get the
probability so it's 16 divided by
whatever 52 times 51 is okay last
example number three here
what is the probability of being dealt a
diamond or a king now this is
interesting this word or sometimes
confuses students in math okay or in
normal everyday language means like I'm
going to go to the store I'm going to
stay home right but in math or means
both it means Union it means like you're
combining those sets and quantities
together okay
whereas and you know you say like I'm
going to go to the store and I'm going
to go to the library it's like you're
going to do both that's everyday
language in math and actually means the
intersection so if I was to draw a
little Venn diagram here for you see n
means this overlapping region right
there okay all the people that are in
your math class and in your English
class okay like for example right now or
would be like all of these people all of
these people but you don't want to
double count the people that are in both
groups right so you have to subtract off
one of those double counting okay so
back to this problem what is the
probability of being dealt a diamond or
a king well you say hmm there's 13
diamonds right okay and how many kings
are there there's four kings but there's
one king of diamonds okay so you're
double counting that so if I could just
kind of circle this here to show you
like here's the Kings one two three four
kings here's the diamonds okay like
everything that's kind of in this group
and you've got that King of Diamonds
that's in both groups so you don't want
to double count it so let's what we're
going to do is we're going to say
probably being dealt two diamonds 13 out
of 52 plus the probability of being
Delta King which is 4 out of 52 minus
the probability that you're dealt
the king of diamonds right because we
counted that one twice we're going to
subtract the probability of being
counted Delta King of Diamonds so if we
simplify we get 16 out of 52 and you can
reduce that further 8 out of 26 or 4 out
of 13 so that's your probability so I
hope you're enjoying these videos I hope
you're learning something I hope it
boosts your math score go ahead and
subscribe to the channel check out some
of my past videos and I look forward to
seeing you in some of the few
your videos I'll talk to you soon